These standing stones are enormous
and made of solid granite.
When you're near them,
they are genuinely impressive and imposing,
the sort of thing that makes you wonder how
ancient people ever managed to raise them up,
and to place them so precisely that
they act as an astronomical calendar.
These particular stones don't
make you wonder that, though.
Because these are the
Georgia Guidestones, in the USA,
and they were put up in 1980 by modern people
with modern equipment.
They are not a theme park
fiberglass replica, though,
they're more than a hundred tons of rock and
they are built to last.
Inscribed on them in eight languages are
what seem to be rules for a
future post-apocalyptic civilisation,
the sort of thing that maybe seemed
like a reasonable way
to send a message to the far distant future
in an era when the Cold War was looking dicey
and Ronald Reagan's finger was
very close to the nuclear button.
The person or people who paid for these stones
stayed anonymous,
so no-one knows if they were actually intending
to troll conspiracy theorists.
Maybe they really were just hoping to create
a modern Stonehenge,
something that could be taken as
a set of principles
for the world's population to follow as we
recovered after an apocalypse.
This might seem like a reasonable purchase,
even altruistic from a certain perspective,
if you're the sort of person who writes a
story in your head that says,
yes, I'll be dead in a nuclear fireball,
but if civilization survives,
perhaps someone will come across these,
perhaps some language will have survived,
perhaps I will have influenced the entire
path of a civilization to come.
It'd take a lot of money and a lot of ego,
but then, it was America in the 1980s,
so perhaps we should just be surprised that there
aren't more stones like this all over the place.
Imagine a dozen different monuments,
all with different rules,
and all being followed by a
different group of survivors.
I don't normally speculate like this in videos,
but these stones inspire some
pretty good stories.
And some pretty bad ones, too.
Because like I said, if you wanted to
inflame conspiracy theorists?
Building a modern Stongehenge,
that acts as an astronomical calendar,
with ten commandments
inscribed upon it,
one of which says that you should
"guide reproduction wisely",
and another says that it'd be
a really good idea
to have a world population under 10%
of what it currently is,
and doing all that while hiding your identity?
Yes, I can see why that might make people with
a slightly tenuous grasp on reality a bit angry.
All the best secret societies, after all,
do put up giant monuments
advertising their goals for the world.
Maybe someday we will know the real reasons
behind these stones:
but until then there's a rule of thumb
called Occam's Razor.
The simplest solution tends to be
the correct one.
And a rich person who saw Stonehenge and thought
"I want one of those"
is a pretty simple solution.
♪ [a faint recording of the US Marine Band playing
"Nearer, My God, To Thee"] ♪